[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis u.s.
chess champ calm presents the third
annual winter just classic hello and
welcome back to the 2019 winter chess
classic as always we are your hosts my
name is Caleb Denby and I'm joined by
the wonderful amazing sabina for ya
thank you it's great to be back uh yeah
it's the sabina you've been here all
five days trudging through these games
talking about them Bensimon filled in
for me a couple times there but it is us
until the end of the tournament that's
sticking it out together
yep hopefully we'll see some we continue
seeing some exciting chests and decisive
results yeah absolutely it's it's been a
bit of a roller coaster with some of
these games that's true a lot of players
getting some very good positions but
especially like bara Kobe and I think
he's he's actually having a bit of a
rough go of it he gets these amazing
positions and then something seems to go
wrong late leading the game for him that
is true yeah seems to be a tough tough
tournament for him for the moment but
you never know he might be able to to
come back you know it's a chess player
you always try to find your form back
it's good to think about okay let's
forget about the past and just try to
play good chess so hopefully that's what
we will see we see a bar hard at work
once again today up there in the
tournament hall well we have a lot of
interesting games to get to today but
first why don't we see where we actually
stand in the tournament the group a
standings have Jeffrey Zhong and you're
not you're not in gym abaya up at the
top there with three and a half out of
five both players on +2 early on in the
tournament Jeffrey of course joining me
not after a big win yesterday again
which I wasn't here for but yeah that's
true that that was an amazing game
actually when you're signing off here's
here's about to win that he had a rockin
game and certainly you know he he took
the the lead early on and then
renourishment I have had a much longer
game against Gregory upon preparing and
that game ended in a truss and now the
two you know top players are in the lead
with three and a half so that's
interesting Lee they play each other
today yeah that's a game we'll keep an
eye on Daniel nerd its key Sam seven and
Grigory Oberon all in joint third place
just a half point behind the leaders of
course Daniel one of the lower rate of
players actually the lowest rate of
player in the a groove coming in so he's
having a phenomenal tournament so far on
a +1 Grigory Oprah and of course the
number three seed also keep an eye on
him to try and make a play and become
one of the leaders who've honest caboose
Ian and Seth you are both on two points
along with Victor Erdos Seth you of
course one of the comeback stories of
the tournament yeah three losses yeah
and I hear one two in a row he came the
other day to talk to us and to me right
cousin you know by myself in the
interviews for the moment but um yeah he
was very excited to come back and I
believe today he also has a very
interesting position so it will have to
keep an eye on maybe if his hot streak
continues so he'll be up with the
leaders before too long it's possible
you know you should never think we have
a scene you know minion that the last
ones can always be first so yes you
never count down anyone everyone has the
chance still until the end so it's going
to be interesting to see that yeah and
in addition we have Alexis tirana and
vara Cobian rounding out the Avery of
standings and why don't we check out the
B group we have Sergey Azeroth and
Alexis oricon both on three and a half
points both of these players have a
great tournament so far they drew their
in round five so hopefully in this round
today they'll try and get that full
point pull ahead yeah I mean they if
they want to try to have a chance to win
this tournament they have to continue
keeping the lead because they are can
really put off the gas
yeah they I mean there's three other
players really close to them
of course those players Mellet CACCI
federico perez poncy and emilio cordova
all on three points looking to catch
those leaders and interestingly the lead
are actually playing these plays that
are just a half point behind today yes
we'll see if there's any mix ups
Taron whoo-hoo root Union has two and a
half points
Justin Wang on two points and
Christopher you all Shawn Marathi Abadi
and Sergei Ehrenberg all on one and a
half points in the B group and why don't
we actually take a quick look before we
get to those games at the tournament
format of course there are 210 player
round robins that's the a group and the
B group that we just took a look at the
time control is 90 minutes for the first
40 moves and then there's 30 minutes
added on for the remainder of the game
there's of course a 30 second increment
from mu of one and there are no draw
offers allowed before blacks thirtieth
move it's to encourage those players to
play some fighting chests keep the games
going until they actually achieve a
result of their result and why don't we
also look at the schedule for the
tournaments we have each round starting
at 1:00 p.m. every day barring that
final round 9 day when the players start
2 hours early to make room for playoffs
if needed our show will be starting at
3:30 p.m. each day and we'll be moving 2
hours earlier on round 9 as well to 1:30
p.m. let's be sure to join us at those
times and of course I would like to
thank you guys for joining us on social
media on I see you guys there in the
YouTube chat shot composer wants to keep
an eye on the Sirkin game we will
definitely be doing that he thinks he
should be an a group actually
interesting maybe if he wins the section
we can move him up for it for next year
I believe that the way the tournaments
are meant to be is you know as strong as
possible yeah for the a group and then
you know B group is not that weak you
know just maybe like yeah those 100
points maybe there's 2500 plus G ends
yeah that don't always get the invites
to the super tournaments yeah yeah just
and youngsters I mean we have two very
strong young players who are trying to
to get their norms here just get some
rating and get some experience playing
against some other strong grandmasters
so it's for sure you know a very strong
tournament so it's hard to say you know
let's put the start of this person there
yeah the one well of course if you guys
want to follow the games for yourself
you can do so on us chess champs calm if
you want to get involved on Twitter you
can also use the hashtag on your screen
there us are I'm sorry winter chess
classic and of course the games are on
us chess champs calm well that's enough
talking about the tournament why don't
we take a look at some games and see our
pairings for the a group we have sethu
playing Varro Cobian Liguria Oberyn
against Victor Erdos Havana's caboose
Ian
against Daniel nerd it's key Sam seven
against Alexis Tirana and then our
leaders faced each other in round six
and what might turn out to be the game
of the tournament
Jeffrey Zhang is playing Renaud Juma
buyeth both players on three and a half
points the co-leaders in the a group and
this game may decide the fate of the
tournament I mean look at that look at
Jeffrey he's really focusing yeah in a
Defen to wants to get that win or you
know it's an incredibly complicated
position today as well it is we're
taking a look at it quickly before the
show started trying to make some sense
of what's going on and they haven't
really made many moves since we got got
on life so it still seems very very
complicated and hard to assess in my
opinion yeah it's the type of position
where the pieces seem a little bit
uncoordinated for both players actually
yeah you have like this this Bishop on
a7 I'm like f2 in that diagonal but then
like the Queen on g6 and the rooks don't
seem to really be coordinating with that
Bishop yeah and it's very similar for
white I mean they do have some pressure
but there are 19 b3 is not doing so
great you definitely can think of a way
to try to improve that night and even if
you have the roofs on the central files
you don't really have a way to get them
more active
right so it seems to be really a tough
position I wouldn't want to I wouldn't
want to have to play this position for
for a wing the colors you know just
feels so so complex you definitely need
to have a lot of time and both players
are you know they they spend quite some
time to get into this position so Jeff
is showing is down to 27 minutes and
pre-namib I of 23 almost minutes so yeah
an incredibly difficult position we're
talking about potential plans to improve
for both sides so the problem piece for
white seems to be this night on b3
mm-hmm so what can we do to get this
night into the game well I was thinking
to do something like bringing the night
to d2 and c4 that seems to be the right
placement for the night in similar pawn
structures but this is very hard to
imagine the opening I mean it was a
French and believe that 493 so you're
just like really how did this position
happen well indeed and I think this
seems like a nice improvement for white
but you know when when you move the
knight from from b3 then you're not
controlling some of the dark squares so
yeah like the a5 pawn might become weak
well what is the 19 C fours you know you
back to it but maybe some Bishop b5 from
black yeah guarding the square it's you
know it's it seems not so obvious on how
to progress I mean black maybe would
like to place his six but if they do
play c6 well we'll get to trade those
pawns and white is the one who will have
you know the do you want rope yeah so
opening of the position my favorite way
what are you I thought maybe it's from
d2 we might bring this Knight actually
to the f3 square okay to get a bit
closer to her pieces on the Kings side
and I would love to see black playing
this movie for of course black never
wants to play evil no no but if black
were to play E for it then my knight
actually does have a very nice home on
that and for square F or DD or and the
whole dark square diagonal I have so
many arrows here yes I feel like Ben in
the background is thinking Sabina once
again you're putting all the arrows he
appreciates that the multicolored makes
the chess it is kind of interesting for
sure
this position is certainly interesting I
I feel really disappointed for not being
able to give our viewers a better
perspective than what we have done but
it does yeah well it's the type of
position where all you can really talk
about is ways to improve right there's
not going to be concrete you know
threats that you can really like point
towards it's gonna be how is white gonna
improve his pieces and what can black do
to improve as well and so for black
we're thinking maybe this c6 idea might
might be be useful to get rid of this D
pawn that's that yeah but what I think
the plan very clearly must revolve
around that improving this I believe so
yeah and maybe another idea I was just
thinking about now maybe try to get this
rope from b8 somehow through b5 try to
you know put some pressure these two
pawns have been pushed a lot for forward
and so you don't really have them backed
up by other pawns like that usually say
if it would be a Kings Indian even have
a policy for protecting d5 but in this
case you you don't and you probably do
not want to play see forecast that way
you're opening up blacks you know you
file so it seems like it's going to be a
pretty pretty difficult position to say
this one looking to be a battle for sure
why don't we take a quick look at the
pairings in the B group actually and see
what we're doing there I think we
actually have some other pretty key
matchups that's true yes for sure
Sergey Ehrenburg is up against Federico
Perez poncy Tigana her route union is up
against Christopher you Malik Koch ian
is playing Alexi Sorokin and this is one
of the games we'll have to keep an eye
on and Sorkin is one of the co-leaders
and Malik of course on three points just
a half point behind with the white
pieces probably hoping to catch up al
Shawn Marathi Abadi is against the
youngster Justin Weng
and our key matchup for the day is
Sergey Azeroth one of the group B
leaders against emilio cordova and this
is shaping up to be a very interesting
game cordova i believe played a very
unique piece sacrifices earlier yes
let's see where we seize this well the
position where that happened was the one
that I just put up on the board so in
this position if we evaluated it just
really seems like black is doing much
better once again this was a French and
when you're playing a French you're
usually expecting this bishop in c8 you
know to be completely restricted by this
chain of ponds and suddenly here we see
something completely different we see
black having the center and it's pretty
well protected and they got their Bishop
out as well which is amazing painting
that 19 f3 and certainly having this
idea to push efore but since you cannot
do it immediately because your night in
a forest hanging Emilia Cordova came up
with this very interesting sacrifice
Knight takes g2 in this position yes we
have to recapture and now efore so it's
a temporary sacrifice you're going to
get your piece back but you are trying
to weaken White's King a little bit and
then of course try to get the remaining
of your pieces into play like you know
that Bishop was already doing really
great nine times three 5s you know when
we were discussing this game a few moves
earlier actually you know you're
pointing out this great idea with 95
maybe even allowing for white in case of
Bishop h6 which actually was played
right to take the exchange we don't care
about it just take it
Cordova maybe a little bit more
responsible eventually he does move his
wreck but I guess he does play 95 yeah
he does really 95 first and just put the
pressure here saying well if you want to
take the route go ahead so I think
probably he was imagining capturing an
f3 right probably with the pawn I would
say I think that's the most
since seems pretty natural just chasing
this bishop away and then when the Queen
will we'll be able to come on the GFL
mates should be very tempting I felt
that this would maybe actually we should
take on f3 wit with the night I think if
you played Mont accept Theory there
might be rook takes e5 looks kind of
interesting and I I've lost count of the
pieces but if you take my rook I'm just
gonna take f3 and I think I've
liquidated a little bit I might be
saving myself I was thinking okay so
this might not work like green tea so
face oh you're trying to meet I am but I
do not see a follow up he's gotta be
insured singing and yeah actually the
others right maybe you could take to
fight first yeah but I think Knight
takes f3 there would have been quite
strong rather alright and then he takes
that fate and Queen g7 is very very
difficult to stop actually even if you
get this with check go there and then
the queen is coming yeah
and checkmate would be imminent yeah so
of course why can't take the rook
so this is a great pawn having an affair
in f6 cuz it's a diagonal exactly five
square no checks no nothing in the keys
and safe so something like this probably
we would have seen in case white was
going to go for the broken of fate but
Sergey Lazarev went for nine to d2
simply you know defending f3 not being
ready to allow for all that to happen
around his king so context of three and
now he recaptures but the problem is he
still stays on this very disturbing
block in this pen and now Cordova moves
his rook and was seeking to h1 and I
believe there were a few more moves made
so now came to h1 certainly you know
preparing some ideas with rook g1 yeah
interesting to know that the
coupon might be hanging yes as little
was not captured it was not captured I I
feel like this should be something for
white in this position well if nothing
else after rook f1 you've kind of
improved White's pieces yes and we
opened we've gotten the pawn bit f6
looks a little bit more week now and the
RIC defends the night quite nicely
yeah so if you move the bishop the Queen
will be able to move as well from the
pin and then white could try to take
advantage of blacks waking to and you
know white scheme doesn't look that weak
anymore it's an interesting decision by
black not to capture this much just King
AJ it's just King a chain and then other
of course for drove to g1 now this is
and you know attracting bishop who makes
f2 even more really wants you to take it
yeah just dig dig the pond to either
pond who's saying but the most it
remains to be seen
if if black would capture so I'm
assuming we will have to expect
accountable care for and so we're back
to the start but the other king is in a
change so yeah let the King untied shade
it and it's unclear to me this this does
look like black is comfortably keeping
the pawn can imagine just bishop back to
a7 would be the simplest and what are
you really doing the plate you need to I
was thinking maybe c1 just yes avoid
like 9 c4 yeah just the purpose of
avoiding some moves through tempo to my
queen and now I went of course going to
f4 try to improve the position of my
queen and we also have potential
captures in e7 I believe there was a
move on the board seems as though black
has not captured on f2 and steady 7
kind of a strange one he guards g7 and
allows this I guess he's just keeping
his King safe seems reasonable
yeah it's and also controlling f7 we
might not think about that right now but
if this night from from f3 and some
points reaches you know there could be
some kind of you know capture capturing
me five
you know discovered in the night of
seven check actually wonder what is it
possible here yeah I guess there's
rookie 101 right exactly that was the
threat yes if you if you were to take
enough to I wonder if this was possible
yeah check there ooh oh I cannot I
cannot I was gonna do five but it's not
it's not it's not double check yeah
there's a bronze but then eventual their
Bishop takes at least black king is
looking very very hmm stuck I don't
think there's any way to control h8 and
also give check yeah I don't know I
don't see that but obviously like
doesn't want this yeah but but you know
with the white you can just give it a
check and then grab one of these bishops
you know maybe maybe this one and then
we have two pieces I think I actually
want the other one you and the other one
um so I want to play King f2 and the
dirty one yeah but I was kind of worried
about leaving living this light square
bishop maybe it's maybe it doesn't
matter boy okay yeah anyways that was
the threat clearly we almost missed it
but Gooden funded 65 so 965 so that's
why black was going for rocky 7 just
simply making sure that that f7 squares
not going to should be something I think
black is actually
actually has some attacking ideas 437 as
well it does clear this e8 square for
the Queen so you can imagine Queen e8
and Queen h5 could come very very
quickly increasing the pressure on this
night and yeah I'm hitting the bishop on
h6 is well potentially yeah of course
and so white is going to need to break
this pence amount he's kind of on the
clock right if you give black a couple
moves Queen h5 will come and your night
falls that's true the only problem is if
you're not you know every single move
you have to make sure that this d5 pawn
will not fall this is a weakness right
now right in the center so Queen d7 to
f5 could be a better route keeping
keeping an eye on on this pond mm-hmm
it's possible so this proves to be a
very interesting game I'm so glad we
went for this as the key matchup of the
day and these seconds are as a rose time
really correct it's it looks as though
she's been getting down just a minute 30
on the clock and he has 18 moves to play
and this a complicated position about
something yeah so clearly is going to
honestly I I think if maybe there's some
way for weight to hold on but this looks
very very difficult looks looks very
tough and going into that time trouble
it's not going to be easy and they have
18 more moves to go so the problem for
white is he already gave the piece back
yeah this pin on f3 is still quite
relevant yeah not sure what how do you
even break this pin and I don't see I
don't think he's very happy about this
position we should at least try and find
one line for white that doesn't lose
right yeah I'm thinking about it I just
I don't seem to see that to be sure to
place c-4 here but it just gives up the
pawn
maybe I've created too many arrows let's
get rid of the arrows okay make it
easier to think about stuff the only way
to break this pen that I see is to play
C 4 and Queen b3 this is the only thing
that I see mm-hmm but f 2 is still
hanging and C 4 I can just take this
pawn if he wants but the night oh yeah
well cuz both can take looks very strong
as well place h3 mm-hmm this is his
attempts you can step back to h5 I'm
anticipating that move unless there are
some tactical ideas and taking an h3
yeah but I'm not so sure you want to do
this you want to allow so many trades
right
then I take d5 fish h5 looks looks very
natural though I think we should fetch
five should not have played because now
you have no other way to continue
pushing the bishop away so this isn't
really solving White's problems it's
just the way it's just delaying I'm
trying to get some extra time I mean
he's in 32 seconds he was close to
losing on time of course it's so it
becomes really stressful I can tell you
I did a few times and there's a similar
time trouble where I had to make so many
moves and I think it was before even the
increments existed so it was
nerve-racking so yes Sergei as Rob head
in his hands thinking about this
position so if you're Amelia Cordova
here do you just play Bishop h5
immediately or do you spend some time
make sure you mean everything you should
you do have that extra time so you need
to spend it wisely in a way like you
know make sure your opponent doesn't
blunder giving the pressure of time but
it's it's very easy to to expect that
they could blunder but they're both
really strong players and playing for
you know all of their lives it's not
like it's so easy to blunder yes you
cannot expect cannot really expect it I
really think this ship age 5 should
happen I'm
you should be thinking a minute max is
this really is this endgame really worth
in 97 and if yeah I think it's very easy
to say no I would say no yes especially
when when you're up time like this
it's it's not so good to you know play
immediately all the time but it is very
nice to keep complications you don't
want to simplify the position for your
opponent you want in fact to give them
options you want to say this I have a
very good position play whatever you
want
mm-hm the problem for them is that they
have to decide yeah forced it's not
training it's it's I have to find
something to do here I feel like he's
spending too much time so I wonder if
there's another candidate move that we
might not be seeing here like trying to
get his Queen and in each farm maybe I
guess some checkmating threat perhaps if
you allow White's to take a bishop in g4
then suddenly they will be fine this
night will finally be able to move so I
don't think that should be something no
I mean Bishop h5 is so simple one of my
rating on this game why don't we go go
ahead and look at some of the other
interesting games we had sure the other
game in the B group is actually this
game between melech ha chin and Alexei
Sorokin Alexei of course another leader
in the tournament and Melek just just
1/2 point behind and so they seem have
achieved this end game oh no we
currently see so white has a queen side
majority as well as the bishop and black
has four pawns on the Kings side to
compensate for it mm-hmm expecting rook
takes c5 seems to be the way to capture
this pawn back I think so yeah with the
rookie definitey although if you're
taking with a pawn you have some ideas
for the night soon to have some you know
some placing before but I think just
about takes rook seems the best actually
be grabbing a pawn right f5 is
when it loose maybe white has some
Bishop III move to try and get b6 in
exchange for it no no I mean but what to
play here where to move the King I will
pick B 1 B 100 is my square
how bad is d3 maybe d3 is good as well
you usually want to try to to get your
King towards the center yes and I
believe of 97 there's there's Bishop e3
maybe that's how white is holding on
I'm not entirely sure black actually
wants to give up this beep on it no
maybe it'll be fine intermediate move
just attacking b2 and then we want to
take the next move yeah but if Rick f2
okay are you taking on f5 still deciding
right my play Bishop takes b6 right yeah
let's let's see what's happening with
that difficult or takes and then b2
Falls and more puns to comment right
yeah yeah this is why my king should be
on b1
that is true but then you know it's an
endgame so you usually try to keep your
king closer to the center so maybe you
know this f5 pawn doesn't seem to be
going anywhere it's on a light square so
you can never really protect it maybe
with a ch3 g4 but when you'll do that
you'll create another weakness in g4
right now you have a 5 as you push the
pawns more forward to defend something
you do live others behind so you have to
be very careful that my feeling position
was that out we need to rock off on this
kind of rank to attack the F pawn yes
maybe white can drive it away somehow
they might try they might try I mean he
malika's has played a lot of very good
end games before and he was probably
confident going into this endgame
because of blacks supposedly bad pawn
structure on the Kings side we have
those double pawns on the F file so
you're thinking all right black doesn't
really have a majority but if you're
going to use the f5 pawn that's going to
be you know quite some problem so you
need you need to be to be cautious here
often times with pawns on both sides of
the board the bishop is better but right
now the 19 g5 is really kind of
restricting that bishop and you rarely
see that like you usually see a bishop
restricting the knight but here the
knight clearly dominates the bishop so
King D 3 was Malik's choice actually he
did like all right so he played King to
d3 okay
I feel like this 97 line looks kind of
promising right 97 B 3 and B 5 and what
to play for white maybe just go back
with the key but then 96 of 505
oh and now Bishop takes me six perhaps
perhaps that night h4 it may be possible
I'm not sure what I mean I'm not sure
black would be happy here to give up
this b6 pawn I think yes that's a
weakness but you'd rather keep that and
just take a five for example what why
not king c6 for example something named
idea and I don't think white has
sufficient time to protect a5 or try to
get another pawn as a matter of fact so
it's going to be difficult now 1897 was
blacks choice looks like we're probably
going to go down this variation all
right and blacks going to end up with an
extra pawn I believe but with four
versus two on the Kings side I'm not
sure exactly how that kind of majority
works out well it depends how far you
will get to push your a or b pawns I
mean the people will be lost the a pond
so if you're going back on the line that
we were just discussing this taking the
rook rook to b5 and look f2 my thing c2
is our choice Casey - yeah because on
work f2 there's no i yeah yeah so I was
thinking deadline that was the line that
you're talking about I wasn't sure if
you wanted to go in the rook end game or
not in this one I thought you were
losing another pawn so I kind of gave up
on on the second you are you are indeed
but you can try to get some activity I
mean all the pawns are on the same side
of the board and your king is close by
so there are some drawing ideas right
it's not going to be easy
yeah a four but plus I think you know
often times you want to make these
direct moves especially if you see an
endgame where you see direct moves yeah
that you often forget to think about
candidate
and that happens to me so often that I
feel like I should probably go back here
and after rookie have to think about
okay just make sure that taking in f5 is
the only move here and clean c6 for
example it's not another option
you know the idea would be okay and like
why would I give you the b-pawn when I
can just take that drink because we're
just discussing it right I'm not sure
you can go key to e4 because I would
just to check you don't you have five
and then just take the pawn no you know
it's very easy to be tempted to make
force forcing moves but just remember to
if you feel like you're going too much
or handing online take a step back and
make sure that your line is really
forcing and you haven't missed some
other great opportunities don't want to
miss calculate me yes yes it's so easy
especially in end games is you think
there's just one straight line but no no
looks quite promising for alexei then
and we do have interesting developments
in the circuit ezra of amelia Cordova
game Emilio was considering another move
so see I told you that my relationship
to h5 he has played Queen e8 offering up
the bishop for free on H takes possibly
Jamie takes g4 and Queen h5 would be an
unstoppable threat okay so he did see
something yeah 90s to trying to remove
the knight would be quite quite
beautiful yeah we're taking the bishop
Josh okay yeah yeah that would be that
would be quite quite interesting but of
course you know see I'm not going to see
that that bishops off limits okay just
give like the chance so ever to capture
on d5 and now how to wearing the Queen
there's rookie Rick d8 maybe you wanna
drink that huh I want to bring the Queen
yeah you can you can bring the Queen
okay so that's it let's let's look at
the candidate move since we just talked
about that I tend to forget my own my
own lessons I simply didn't see where
the Queen was going after
d8 maybe me three but that looks quite
bad I was thinking maybe for you four
nights to d3 does it work maybe let's
find it it looks like an ax
yeah seems like it is working nasty
nasty stuff and Queen B 3 maybe now I'll
play Queen Age 5
just continue naturally
it just seems very difficult for a why
to defend and he actually has gained ten
seconds compared to the other position
yeah well but it's one of those
situations it's like well taking the
mission fuzes moving anything losses
I guess I'll play this move which might
lose yeah but at least I will lose with
a belly full meaning you know this is
actually how the game has continued you
got some material interestingly though
maybe Rick d8 while it was very natural
was was incorrect so if you look here
after Knight takes e5 and so rook da
Queen b3 Queen h5 maybe Knight takes e5
is the way to try to hold on for for
white now the Queen on v3 it's actually
quite useful as it defends this h3 pawn
from afar and so sure sure we could take
the knight and I'm not entirely sure how
the line would continue but we do have
this extra defender with with the Queen
on on the Xperia which is if you picture
this position with the Queen on d5
Bishop takes h3 but simply when the game
of course yeah so he did go for rue de
that was played on the board right
yeah and it's one of those situations
where maybe this is where you should
spend your extra time yeah White has
committed to this very forcing line
where he's probably just losing and so
once he's already committed you don't
want to play these one move forcing
moves right you want to keep those in
your back pocket you want to sit and you
want to figure out the position that's
for sure like especially when you see
the king is weak and you want to attack
it so I think it was was much better I
think this should be sitting to deal
very soon hmm
yeah you're threatening tonight and if
if Knight takes Knight there's a variety
of options dad but but also just taking
here and so you boy yeah white boy to
move the Bishop Luers yeah really maybe
if I would be the only thing to do but
then
you're just losing to Bishop h3 I think
I guess you do have this annoying
discovery so I'm not sure
the idea being you're forcing me to move
my queen away and now okay it takes
maybe there are some complications yeah
for sure there are complications I mean
this is this is a position were thinking
about yeah that's very important to
spend a lot of time on there's a key
moment in the game where you have to
spend time try to figure out you know
actually so sorry starting knight Knight
takes e5 maybe simply rook takes e5 is
is quite strong and you can take on b7
but I don't think that's the most
relevant thing in the world I can play
just rich e8 and my king is safe and I
could care less about my bishop on on a
seven well I might be able to bring some
defense real not as much maybe not
Bishop a forage to something like that
I'm thinking it's a Bishop h3
taking well no if if you don't think
you're to go to or yes
it clearly advantageous for black yeah
to be made but there's a lot of a lot of
good lines to consider for sure yeah
this Queen h5 would have been probably a
better choice but he decided to go for
oth Oh interesting
wait this is the current position and
Amina Cordova now is thinking it's still
of course quite pleasant for black but
maybe not all that it could have been
mm-hmm okay so where do you want to jump
to now let us go back maybe to the a
group a little bit
I see another kind of crazy position in
the game between de Bruijn and not a
dead ski what do you think about that
position my goodness since crazy III you
know I was just scrolling through the
positions and this one seemed the most
interesting well it is nerd that sees
move actually night F to check is a
possibility of course Bishop takes would
be the only move but then you would be
made yeah yeah it takes yeah we need to
go with this other night enough to that
was that's the idea b3 so night DF to
rook F to pawn takes up Toulon and
what's going on there's this black
winning seems very unpleasant for white
dad I can tell you for sure Age 3 I
think should be played and maybe he did
play something yes he did play oh sorry
I thought it was blacks moved there I
sorry no III was just played okay with
that idea so this seems to be the only
move that kind of holds the position
because there was no I mean I've seen
this kind of this is a very typical
tactical idea that if you haven't seen
yet you should definitely study your
night mates
night if to just trying to get ready to
fish up away from g1 and then you're
meeting in h2 so you know h3 seems the
only plausible
maybe h4 - but h3 you know you you don't
want to take chances to weaken your
position too much if
it's not really necessary so always
think step by step pawn pushes there
aren't ways to continue those for black
Daniel actually chooses an ADF to check
anyways
forcing I think this should take SEF to
you for real this time
now that mate isn't hanging I mean your
question is do we take with the night he
does take back with a knight
I'm giving Chuck I have a worry here
subpoena okay
my worry is that the next moves I'm
gonna be king h2 black is going to play
now they're going to go for this drum
ing one for white after my very exciting
decision to come to this game not a true
draw ducks there became g1 yeah they
could be king g1 that takes up to I mean
Kim Ji Won is is the way to play of
course you could give the exchange back
you know buds have to let's see what's
happening
do we have something here with Mac it
looks dangerous still does look
dangerous we still have some checks over
here
actually maybe we can play queen takes
up five and where are you are you sure
he's coming from are you sure you can
make that move I'm not sure I'd like to
hmm I put all my pieces on light squares
claim that I'm safe no I feel like there
should be some sacrificing g3 and trying
to lead for a mate for some maid somehow
so white has actually given the exchange
back so let us feel good when I can
guess that oh wow
they're already there yeah can you
believe that okay some anticipating a
check rook to d1 check
it's a rook t1 King h2 is is quite
forced CMAs yeah because you cannot put
the bishop here then you're entering
under some other very annoying ideas and
pins so you have to go King h2 and they
feel that they show up two three four
it's possible there should be four
rather and these checks I guess don't
last forever
four four white maybe my King can come
to g6 yes for sure so that that's the
whole idea I want to bring the King to
g6 and then trying to figure out if I
have a mate that's that's my goal just
concede yet yeah I think maybe maybe
Queen f5 is the best try jerk check and
run and no matter where you check me
we'll try to run again yeah I mean the
black has this problem of bringing their
queen closer closer to the game you
cannot use the C 1 square e 3 is not
going to be sufficient because I was
thinking of some idea maybe like this
and then sacrificing G 3 but doesn't
seem to be enough because King takes and
now I don't have or do I let's see Shaq
trying to get you out to the king and
try to utilize my rook from the D file
scary seems scary I mean it remains to
be calculated I think though maybe
earlier in the line White had something
judging by by what I've put on my my
laptop here ok of course yes ready one
mm-hmm h2 and now Bishop d4 maybe Queen
e2 it's a possibility
simply attacking the rook preparing to
checkmate black and preventing this this
idea of bishop g1 with this windmill
time tactic by by putting the strip
under pressure
I see I think yes I think the computers
got this one right okay Bishop g1 sure
King H one and there's there's not much
to do for what for like really yeah I
wanted to bring my queen on to be closer
but I'm scared of now getting both the
rook and the Queen into the games we
hate I think it's and I think I can play
Rick c7 maybe I take it back and I
should have won to escape
yeah to run away so this is the escape
for you and their watch is winning yeah
the see fun would would be worth a
bishop so something else for black then
can't really put this Rick on d1 may be
simply Bishop d4 first
yeah but then if you bring the bishop
first yes you're keeping your roof to
keep your King protected but then you
don't really have a mating attack so
that's just something that you have but
it's not a mating attack but you're
going for the b6 pawn you might give up
the b7 it's interesting I wonder if I
could just capture that f5 bonus we were
thinking previously yeah maybe this is
this is just fine for life if not more
okay so I think they agreed to own a
true Bishop DeForest play then I saw a
handshake I see nobody resents so I
think the think it is peacefully for
these two players all right well I guess
I didn't pick a good one
well we came just as the complications
we're settled and it was interesting
very interesting developments actually
in the Jeffrey jean game against Regina
by of decisions have been made a very
important decision subject so we
actually have the structure has changed
slightly mm-hmm so earlier when we were
looking we saw these black pawns on f5
and E 5 and now the black has been
forced to move this pawn to e4 which
gives up some some very important
squares I'm not sure if really forced or
he just oh he just did himself so he
thought that was a good idea and that's
interesting usually you try to keep the
doubled pawns more compact right it
makes some sense to keep the pawns on
light square just to bother White's
light square bishop but I feel like
you're giving up you know this square
for the knight which yeah you'd quite
quickly with thank you for Ricky fine
and now we have Queen f4 from Geoffrey
so as always I guess I'll ask is that
one is that a finger can be captured
goodness it's always so complicated
there will be some discovery here I can
assure you I just I'm not sure when
maybe we have to trade the Queen's and
now if I play Knight takes f5 you'll
simply play rook takes f5 hmm maybe I
can throw in rook takes d6 first trying
to gain in tempo yeah I think you should
be very careful all rook takes off too
and then I'm using them I'd wind me
right so Bishop a5 would be forced and
then you know this you're 56 looks quite
good for black I think so unless you're
getting some extra pawns this the pair
of bishops should be much stronger than
the rook yes so what's what's the line
then for Geoffrey what happens after he
takes d5
what can we do
it's not that easy maybe we can just be
happy that we're trying to get the
default opened and not actually go do it
for the effects so just take 93
I want a defend a 5 but maybe I don't I
don't think it matters maybe maybe it
matters and I'd be three and no we are
but wait I think there's this move looks
thinner weird I know you don't like it
you can see I could see you're like what
what are you saying
Bishop f1 right yeah but then I take
I'll take that right enough is enough
pawns seem to fall yeah yeah okay that's
that was too much it looked beautiful to
put the look there but yeah with the
nineteen be three I cannot do that
indeed alright so so maybe Geoffrey
would get the pawn back on d6 yeah
that's probably his idea I mean he just
want to take wants to take they're going
for a stakes trying to improve the
position of his rooks finally because
the position are so locked down we
didn't think the Roosters coming to play
but now well as these players get low on
the clock they are actually playing a
bit more quickly now and you have a few
more moves played I believe black did
not capture on d5 no black one Farouk I
brought this other book but now that the
rook vacated the B file Geoffrey felt a
little bit better about opening it maybe
and all right so now it makes sense cuz
the rook is gone but the ROO can always
come back on that file and now he's
trying to do is just protect his d5 pawn
why just like has actually captured d5
now mm-hmm
before it's too late yeah because if you
love Percy for but now no a5 it's going
to be attacked and if you will retrieve
you the 19 b3 there will be Ruby 8 yes
so what happens on these same lines that
we were looking at trade pros read I'm
assuming punch Dante looks the most
natural no do we go for diabesity again
I think maybe now there's Reformation
misses my books no it's over it's not
over until we say it's over and then I
was right back to G for all these inner
menses so we do have Queen takes d6 from
Geoffrey on the board seems like the
only reasonable move yeah so the current
position
is the current position
they are both really getting a long time
but okay they only have to make eight
moves it's not that bad
so 93 there might be a problem with your
diagonal maybe rut takes d1 through
Bishop a4 and Bishop a4 I'm not sure
this one the computer wasn't telling me
it's a good maybe I hope to be eight
yeah I'm keeping my extra pawn this is a
point oh well that's still a weakness
and this is a weakness that we could try
to go maybe sure maybe I can take b1
mm-hmm and then go back in Annoying
movie three oh I want to kill you
problems that's not your right that's a
very good move
so I kind of have to take it if I love
for 32 or our takes is pretty bad so
then you take and then King up one I
want to play beef Bishop e5 Bishop b3
and I think your knight is simply dying
yeah that's really beautiful restricting
the night completely you have to go 93
and your night will be dead over there
and then should say 5% one just miss the
night yes c1 maybe keep an eye on em hmm
so problems for Jeffrey Brown problems I
don't like this night b3 you went for
nine takes of fire affectionate
opposition this is giving the the two
pieces for the rock unless unless is
going to go for room takes a five now
rope takes this surgery you can play
that put any free maybe there's nothing
yeah that's what we had discussed a
little bit earlier so we need to see if
that really works cuz there's a room 67
well there's even Bishop f2 there should
be one I thought was just the simplest
just just getting this this that's rook
and then we're sorry sorry
okay I still you still have an extra
piece yeah yeah this cannot be home demo
so portable 9f5
just okay there have been some looks
like returns for sure takes bishop takes
in the rickety five Bishop h3 is all on
the board so Bishop f5 Bishop f5 Ricky
Rick D for a why why did he go for that
I I don't think there's a better option
what could you do here know why he
didn't go for a look at five you did
okay so Rick I thought he went for
Bishop Oh finally yeah that's why I was
like well that's very strange
yeah I know I know what are we doing I
guess it's very similar but I feel like
you lose a tempo on this line the one
that he I mean maybe maybe he's actually
winning in line if he goes for this
maybe he's winning a move let's see this
compared this position maybe that's what
he was going to go for and now why takes
in d6 and we could have this position or
we could have this position one with the
bishop on h3 might be bit I guess that's
what he he thought it'll be better cuz
you know the bishop here keeps White's
King under pressure I'm unconvinced
honestly it's demonstrate my or upon
rather might get attached where k-6 is
still coming knows for sure something
but III you showed me that move that
move gets very annoying yeah dad yeah I
love that move I it's actually held me
it was part of the the game that I
played that brought me the title of US
Women's Champion that III just opening
up an opponent's king this and now
devastating actually yeah of course I
think fe3 is the the only move then
Bishop III and King edge won but then
the the bishop to anywhere on that
diagonal is is simply going to be
checkmate well you will push the H pawn
as soon as I move my nice finish up you
will go to H pawn for sure but there's
this invert being yes think about it
take my bishop take my bishop so daebak
ranking and now we want to look to be
- Bishop e2 is checking how you will
defend that Oh No d3 maybe you just try
to harass this Bishop until it leaves
this is this is not good for Geoffrey I
don't think so no he doesn't get to take
a 6 if he doesn't get to take that pawn
these bishops could be very annoying but
maybe he can just you know follow this
Bishop as you're saying and there might
not be no dopey shop F - doesn't seem
yeah I have to play route 81
mm-hmm and then try to use the D 2
square to trade but what about Bishop
you may be sure Beth oh you have this
check now yes for the moment but here's
a move
King g7 right just step out and then
what can happen
III is on the board as we expected and
this is actually huge news for the
tournament if we're not manages to
suppress your Geoffrey hearing and get
the full point that's a huge upset that
season the board I didn't get that
refresh okay I got it yeah just just
looking for Cameron and if we're not
room abaya wins this game then the
tournament kind of gets flipped on its
head
Chris Jeffrey the favor going in still a
leader today if he loses here this is
it's going to overturn the tournament
and he does have quite some time to
think but it's not pleasant I mean you
know I played before with two rook
forces to pieces yeah but against two
bishops it was always something that I I
tried to avoid playing because you
Commission's just especially there's
almost no pawns in the center right it's
completely open that your King site is
open yeah you're gonna get attacked and
no just a little every square on the
board yeah and the king is completely
like closer to being mated there in each
one it doesn't seem like you can find a
way to escape with the king
so retention map I've certainly chose
the right move Bishop to h3 instead of
you know keeping it in a5 as we're
looking at the lines so this is you know
sometimes these move orders and this
very tiny changes could really have a
big impact in the game kind of like in
that game that we're looking earlier or
versus Cordova right queenie 8 versus
queen h5s nice routine da bringing
helping white get the Queen in b3 and
then is able to protect 3rd rank and
here the bishop is creating very
annoying mating threats which are going
to be very hard to to defend by Geoffrey
so we're not Geoffrey is still still
thinking this one over but I just simply
don't see it another choice
besides fe3
yes there's there's nothing to be done
in and let's actually try and find a
winning line how about it okay
I believe I mean it's just F III Bishop
III must be correct
King h1 and then we were thinking about
this rook b8 move but we weren't totally
certain well I was trying to try to I
mean I I think that was good idea III
bishop after I think this line so far
seems pretty good I was actually
thinking about the move like a rook to
be - I'm not sure if it's good or not
might not be good enough because you go
Rudy - which Rucker
I'm not I'm not sure we actually do have
a result in groupie Melik kocham has
drawn his game against tournament B
leader Alexei Sorokin selects me moves
to four out of six
giving Sergei perhaps a chance to jump
into the lead although he is still under
a little bit of pressure against Emilio
Cordova yeah but it seems like he was
able to get back into the game still no
moves here yet why don't we stick with
this Jeffry can actually because this
looks yeah obviously put quite
interesting so Rick me too you're
thinking maybe Rick 3d2 Eric one D to
one of the Occident and one more result
sethu has won his game against Varro
Cobian that brings Seth through to a
three game winning streak he replaced
his three game lost streak with a three
game win streak and he moves to three
out of six 50% as he said maybe we'll
get him down for an interview again I
think we should yeah let's let's see how
he's feeling today about his wayne and
take us through his game I didn't really
have the chance to look at that very
much
right yeah so that would be it would be
great to get him and I think we're
working on that yeah we'll have them in
momentarily why don't we take a look at
some of these other group a games that
we haven't had a chance to see yet how
is Grigori oprand doing in his game
against Victor Erdos we see the players
there it looks as though Grigory has the
two bishops the black has a very
comfortable space advantage on the Queen
side and perhaps this is
not so good for Grigory this is my few
debts that's a plan that eventually you
want to do but you will wait you're not
rushing for that sure but why does have
the pair of Bishops which they're about
to trade hmm
and and the problem is you don't really
want to be left with this LightSquared
bishop it's a little bit boxed in both
by these these black pawns very nicely
placed ending in c4 and your own pawn on
e4 also keeps this bishop very much out
of the game that's true and you often
can think that if you're going to stay
with the bishop versus an I teach in
most cases it should be better and you
see this 1984 and you're thinking now
whatever that night is better place but
know that that would be a really wrong
quite strong yeah it is very strong it's
it's putting pressure on c3 which if
you're going to trade the dark square
bishop it's going to be a pawn to to be
looking out for one of your other pieces
and this Knights also can come very
easily into play back to c5 maybe d3 or
just be placed in c5 and support the
majority on the Queen side so yeah well
while you take a look at this I'm
actually going to hop out of my seat
here and we'll get to it all right so
certainly this is a very interesting
game here we have a move by Victoria she
went for Bishop to e5 and then we
immediately had a response by a parent
both players are really very long time
so we're going to expect fast moves in
this position g3 trying to improve the
position of that light square bishop
we're talking with Caleb a little bit
earlier try to play some f4y does need
to start pushing the pawns on the Kings
side here because that's where they have
the majority and we are we have Setzer
among in the studio with a very nice
swing today congratulations thank you
you are back on 50% thank you after
three losses you're back to three wins
yeah how does it feel it feels good to
recover
okay of course I didn't have to lose
three games and the minigames but it's
fighting yeah yeah
was there anything that you have done to
try to get back into the tournament
we're talking a little bit with you
after your first or anything but yeah
probably I I was not preparing lunch and
I was relaxing a bit because it's
already already my third tournament so I
relaxed a bit done and probably I was
what you just lacked a little bit and
traveling from not really it's my I came
from Europe so it's my 31 like I pretty
night off man and then I'm bad busy and
then here it's like but it's of course
it's very exhausting after Tom Collins
yeah so you just try to just relax a
little bit yeah play some good chess
it's good to see so take us through your
game today did did you
Varis usually playing the other French
to the French
so is this preparation yeah probably a
lot of days I already played in I love
men in the second round
okay it was interesting quite
interesting way to I mean the new way
new trend yeah
so generally they play 22 B Phi and then
it goes yeah yeah that's a lot of theory
is quite interesting so Bishop I mean
take stakes yeah Bishop c4 windy too
long Castle in the biggest game my mixed
up the mortars with long castle mmm-hmm
and then against an alien in the Isle of
Man okay so yeah then she took on d4
with the bishop mm-hmm and then she took
on b4 and she got some counter play with
be fine uh-huh b5 before just yeah
coming fast
yeah well it's clear that you're going
to Castle long anyways yeah so h4 is
quite accurate water so today I didn't
mix it up so nice because the
differences it paid for after I mean if
she if he takes with the bishop or d4
instruct 94 okay then I have not long
cast earlier so I can even go short
Castle sometimes like after Bishop of
tour something yes haha so just go back
yeah Bishop do you put it in neat or d3
from the deuce I mean the game he played
94 yeah you should defer before me and
so well now you cannot really cast a
short anymore because those bishops will
be traded yeah I have pretty good attack
compared to his I'm incrementing before
so so quite normal h5 yeah until here I
prepared and oh yeah I was a mess
preparation and here black has to play
at 6 mm-hmm I mean stopping my head 6
and then bro cash 3 and it's slightly
better oh okay what about ideas with you
for yeah it's coming after her but yeah
but making sure ideas like before like
at the game always like when he plays
Bishop T Sun so it's slightly better for
me but that's all my preparation ended
kind of okay we should be something it's
a mistake from just I think losing on
the spot 6g 6b yeah no no this is very
weak it's yeah yeah
people it might be something I can take
on d5 maybe so but 97 nobody really yeah
I mean just I mean if not to lose the
pawn on e6 yeah
so this yeah meaning tough I had this
option of taking on d5 but it was I
didn't want to risk so he 6 yeah my
Quincy 3 so he D son mm-hmm Queen III
checking the to Queen B - okay still
white should be better but okay and I
mean the game looked quite simple so I
thought why don't go here yeah he does
have quite some weaknesses over here yes
take take Andrew K 1 maybe I mean but in
the game what I played was quite simple
so you just went for the trade I mean it
and then take the pawn
yeah and now it's going to be very
difficult for black yeah you have seen
at this position it's already I think
it's an extra pawn and doesn't seem like
Platt has any way
yeah yeah yeah but this is also typical
but with the pawn down is certainly
going to make his life more difficult
okay I found this nice idea with c4 yeah
just look at through you to say it would
be to look b6 + C photo spine and I
think the Arab Caesars is coming so c4
was quite nice
because if he takes it upon their Queen
d7 yeah now this point is going to be
notion of mini so yeah yeah just coming
yeah and if he trades okay this yes
should be I mean if Ruby five foreign
students and I can just look in situ I
could be fine and takes takes gives me
three maybe three and then you have to
bring your look
yeah king of a king before I don't know
why you want to give up this to let let
your opponent with those two pawns but
maybe maybe it's fine okay we have some
of the better options - I thought this
should be winning as well like king
before king he someone for instance
mm-hmm I just can take and c3 you look
h1 and you go back yeah to block it down
you're coming right back with the king
yeah yeah oh yeah he by one tempo he
doesn't make it to protect the d5 pawn
yes
yeah but then be fine I have okay I mean
the same idea yeah this super looks nice
and now Queen takes and I really wish I
could play rook c6 but you know just go
to see yeah yeah this is just very
annoying yeah just so yeah meaning so
some c4 c4 can be to where all right it
seems like we have just a new result
circular Ehrenberg draw against para
sponsor so we're gonna be looking at
that game until later all right throw
takes c4 and now yeah if you have the
fire
furthest away possibly for instance if
you place a d4 then I have a look at one
most yeah but before ya I mean to stop
rook c3 yeah okay
then you go to page one and to come up
see one and then you go back like
already the potion is quite and here ah
you're just offering the trade yeah
another for beef no you cannot take beef
beef
oh you have been [ __ ] before and then
you take this point and you're in the
box of the pun
yeah right look uh for b5 check that
looks like - again I can do the same
thing mm-hmm so check how kinky one
looks nice because the point is that
African b1 if he goes like instance king
discern then I have Shahrukh see son
check King date and rusev on this was
the difference between King on c1 king
on p1 I know it's his because he cannot
just come this way because the part on
g2 is very strong yeah and then you go
there it's kind of interesting you know
that you get this point in age six and
but you keep the other one eg two and it
kind of helps yeah history they're like
yeah completely legitimate rule here
alright so again yet to play the check
if again I mean the same thing a fluke
have to check you would go oh where
would you be three Ruby to rook c8 check
King D sound looks is on check and I'll
take one epsilon and Susan and if I come
back
yeah is just b7 yeah so if you go still
I mean I mean volunteer to like province
on this book b3 check on Turkish treats
now you take their and it's known that
this pawn can be very annoying game and
and then all right after King King
decided to just enter everything yeah
very very nice game and yes thank you
Congrats or for your win nice nice
comeback in the tournament yeah you have
three people it's in three more rounds
what do you feel how do you feel about
the last last three yeah good fight like
I don't know like it's three losses and
three wins it's like been fighting right
fighting really well so we are hoping
for
to finish it all right well we wish you
good luck thanks for joining us today
and taking us through our game and we'll
see you hopefully we'll see her again
soon
sure thanks all right so well we have
had that result as I mentioned
Grandmaster Sergei Arenberg drew his
game against better sponsor Frederico
this was the final position of the game
and they agreed on a draw on move 36
completely blocked opposition it doesn't
seem like white can have any ways to
improve the position of the rook so they
went for the drop all right and we
should go back
caleb is coming right back
joining me yeah so let's see how things
have progressed since the last moment we
have seen this position III q2 h1
Wow all right
Wow very unique defense from Jeff feel
free to promote I don't care I'm joking
it's check so now rook to d1 deciding to
give back they exchange an f1 when you
promote a better move for for black
should I remove this Bishop Geoffrey was
hoping for f1 in which case I think he
actually has pretty good chances to hold
the endgame yeah I mean Queen capture
Bishop takes well I'm not so sure if he
has that many chances yeah but it's upon
will be lost like all I need to do is
just put my bishop in b5 in case you're
going to protect your look on face rank
and bring my bishop I should be able to
capture I mean it's yeah but for sure
Bishop d7 is a much nicer move by black
here you need to play King G - that's
right
and now this is our almost our current
position but I do want to mention our
key matchup of the day in the B group
has officially ended Cordova
let something slip there and Sergei Ezra
of actually escaped with a draw oh wow
so he
surprise there sure yeah we're talking
maybe Cordova rushed things Bay you know
he had 20 extra minutes on his clock and
instead of taking his time trying to
find that the crushing win he let's
Sergei escape and Sergei playing very
accurately under time pressure with just
seconds on his clock made it to move 38
and that is when I'm you know decided to
call it just call it a draw I wonder if
I could have one of the players join us
maybe if we could get Sergei down here
yeah we have not had him you haven't
talked to him we haven't talked to him
yet let's see if we can still catch him
before he leaves her purse Sergei going
to be at least in joint first after
today tied with Alexei Sorokin up there
on the top of the groupie leaderboard
and so things looking just dead lost for
Geoffrey I'm sorry we didn't we did not
we did not expect for this share of
advance and it's kind of tough when
you're playing white pieces you're the
leader you're also number one player in
the event I don't know how much pressure
he puts on himself we had him twice for
an interview and he seems very confident
in general and not stressed out about it
like it's good it's I feel that he has a
very good way of approaching the game
not too much pressure at least he
doesn't show it right but certainly now
he has a very tough position if you
manage to defend this it'd be great yeah
I can't I can't imagine a world where
it's very difficult it's very difficult
for him though yeah unfortunately you
know Geoffrey's a tremendous player of
course but his opponent is as well and
why don't we check out some of these
games in the B group that we have that
we have this game between Alshon
marauder body and Justin Wang what is
happening in that positions been a while
since I checked it things don't seem to
be going so well for for Justin okay
so Wyatt it seems to be up upon and with
this last move it's been played took to
b7 putting additional pressure on blacks
two weaknesses a7 and f7 aiming to get a
second poem then yeah thank you so much
to be done about it yeah you have to see
exactly how you take it because of
course there could be some my district
Bishop c4 trying to look at e to right
palm but if you you know have the rook
on 7th rank which is really awesome you
always have the ability to play rook e7
and just protect your pawns that would
be certainly something to expect from it
shaping up to be a technical endgame
that hopefully we'll see also and be
able to convert yeah that would be great
it seems like unfortunately grandmaster
author of has left the building
catch him I wouldn't catch him in time
no worries there well we'll catch him on
one of those days when he for sure for
sure one of their interesting games to
do we have yeah and what about
harutunian against Christopher you so
this actually looks quite interesting
Christopher you with some very active
rooks and some pressure on the White
King actually I think he's got quite a
nice position here so it is black to
move rook h2 was white shirts in point
no and then Rica yeah Rick f2 has just
been played and this is our current
position
so what's to be done here night h6 looks
like a pawn if yeah yeah I mean this
this one isn't blacks territory so for
sure they can capture it any time but
you always have to make sure you will
not be pinned that's kind of what we
need to make sure it's not going to
happen both players are looking in the
same time something must have happened
it's both of them we're looking around
in the same time you know yes
it's rare that you see both players some
noise some disturbance and some
disturbance that's not good
Christopher you seems very confident in
his position there when I was a kid I
remember I was moving my leg a lot it
just it just becomes kind of a you know
yeah motivational thing you feel like it
gives you energy he's like so he's young
he's got energy to spare too much energy
so what is going on he's thinking about
attention to capturing the pawn like as
a few options here right you can trade
rooks first of all and simply play King
takes h6 and you will in fact be up a
clean pawn
maybe that's the simplest can also just
play move like either rook to f4 and
kind of keep the tension and allow white
to actually be the one to capture yeah
just enough quite sure which one we want
to move either this e1 or or the f1 I
mean it's a nice tension but you also
have to think about potentially Bishop
e3 coming in back or sample yet
regardless though it's looking Pleasant
for Christopher here maybe I will be
able to press in the same game quite a
bit yeah certainly has a better position
and with the black pieces getting this
against pretty strong player that's very
impressive got to be is
something you're not letting go you know
you need to continue pressing it's not
like you know you're not going to go go
ahead and offer a draw yes as a lower
seat in these tournaments you really got
to look and press these chances as hard
as you can yes you're not gonna get them
too often
I can such a strong field but that's
just so as the lowest seed Christopher
definitely going to be looking to make
the most of his chances here
Geoffrey genres has officially resigned
his game against Renaud Juma by of
course we were expecting that one we're
not moving into sole first with four and
a half out of six with that result
nobody will be able to catch that score
and unless Sam seven or degorio proned
win their game today he will be a full
point ahead of the field yeah we should
try to get him down here for an
interview why not if absolutely if he's
let's hope he does not leave the
building and Buster's Sergey Lazarev did
they should be able to kitchen I didn't
mention another really important game in
a group is this game between Gregorio
Oprah and Viktor Erdos came up very
important developments happened namely
black I think did eventually capture
this Bishop on d4 changing the structure
and they do have a piece pawn up yeah we
were around earlier earlier maybe move
30 efficiency or Bishop e5 this should
be v g3 pawn alright that was to be
expected
yes eventually because I mean if you're
going to to trade your pair of bishops
you should do it well I'll let you catch
up to present day here I'm gonna get out
of my seat actually and letter or not
Jim abaya have joined us to talk about
his big victory Oh Geoffrey Jean all
right so then we had Bishop to g4 a
rogue d 8:22 okay so why just trying to
get away from these very annoying pawns
but she will start pushing
Knight to be too okay
trying to create some attacks on the
Kings side of course but it seems like
this efore pawn will remain weak and
then
rook takes e4 white is trying to get
some activity but with a pawn down
I don't think I don't think that should
work Knight to d3 I really like I really
like black in this position unless I'm
missing something there should be there
should be going in blacks favor but we
have the men of the day here with us
today Renaud Juma by Oh congratulations
nice nice game today tell us how do you
feel about you know about the event in
general yeah yeah every game is very
interesting especially today's game was
too complicated I cannot understand the
phone we were trying we we were not sure
what the plans were at some point yeah
very difficult to understand which he
should do what should I do what I should
do and maybe I didn't even know where he
made a mistake because so what are you
expecting this opening I guess I was
expecting eyes widened this one even
nice history I I was analyzing that
before okay I didn't expect that he
can't play he can play Knight c3 in this
game but it was one of the possible
Alliance 9 3 6 96 the it was a move I
prepared for this game
mm-hmm 92 in 5d 595 Queen d3 d5 until
Bishop g2 I knew or two after Bishop d2
did you I thought well I was signalizing
longest four maybe I remember yeah
position is still very unclear and okay
maybe it's dynamic equal position but he
has some ideas I have some
okay I have two pair of Bishops and
potentially strong Center but he is
better developed and very good chance to
attack my King because my King is in the
center mm-hmm all right but so Bishop g2
yeah yeah castle f5 I have to play a
fight because if I don't play a five he
can fix me on the white squares and and
of course you this is this seemed like a
very natural move for white actually I
just have to say that we have a new
result in Group A Sam Savion drew
against Serrano so that's another game
that was finished but let's get back to
the head to this one so a for a for
before before but but this move like
well this doesn't seem didn't seem so
clear to us was this better for white or
black because sometimes it's typical but
then you know suddenly this pause
they're just kind of not so well
protected yeah right by another pawn you
don't really have like a clear chain how
you're going to improve this I mean
you're blocking the position on the
queenside in a way but do you think
maybe a four was not something that I
should play here no it's also good
option because he cannot die he doesn't
want to
[Music]
I play Knight C for this maybe after
night c4 Knight I can take on b2 maybe
my knight is going to d6
or after you even 285 somehow since our
moments
maybe it's very difficult to understand
h3 was the principle auctioneer yes play
is faster we don't think you should play
this move with black but it proved to be
a really ahead to great idea yeah
because
I cannot protect on that five and
because of efore but I have some forces
ideas here because if Queen D for I can
play Bishop f6 of Queen d2 94 and it's
maybe Bishop g5 also
maybe we should be five maybe Ruby six
rook h6 or g6 I have at some moments
maybe this ship c5 as I played in the
game and the queen is going to f6 or
yeah in the nitrogen brought into the
game maybe now now with the pawn being
pushed earlier you can yeah and then you
got into this position
nice 94 is very strong I didn't see how
kick he can play because after Bishop h3
I can play me for yeah it doesn't seem
natural that white would want to trade
your 1985 but yeah it's amazing that I
cannot play a four because after Bishop
before mmm okay can you take no I can't
take then no in maybe is the main line
to take only four instead of c4 Queenie
for king of 895 Bishop h3 and but after
Knight f4 Bishop f1 rook a fun I think
I'm worse because when a queen bee 2 is
not working because of Queen f5 mm-hmm
just why just yeah 96 96 this position
is very dangerous it's kind of
interesting that in your game you you
ended up winning with a nice pair of
bishops but here's a pair of knights
yeah yeah of course but okay so it makes
sense to go for the trade and this was
about the time that we got in life and
we were we were looking at the position
trying to think what aren't exactly the
plans for both colors because of course
you are
white is improving the position a little
bit but then you have the Queen eg-6
protecting your king maybe you're going
to push the pawns that was something
that these two pawns I thought white was
to be worried about I thought maybe you
should play a five not white but I don't
know maybe that proved to be a weakness
for for him to play a five having the
pawn no it's not a weakness after white
plays d5 a 5 for Bishop e7 my 86 pawn is
can be always hanging dead 31 Bishop f1
and any endgame position can be worse
for me because of the a6 pawn true but
it makes sense to play five his wife the
other question I could play a five
before here instead of Queen g6 or
before that instead of cusping maybe
that's how moments but here my g2
I didn't like and b3 after that and my a
five is also because I cannot move my
bishop on b6 yeah and we got into this
position and we were surprised do you
want is a mistake d1 yeah he played very
fast
maybe Queen h5 is a principle move
because I cannot play Queen g6
because of take take and g6 and this is
decent game could be worse for me yeah
that definitely trying to get this rook
into place yeah not the best locating
piece yeah I was calculating efore 94
and
rook a5 Bishop f5 this becomes very
messy yes
maybe it's very strange position can you
take and qui g6 no cuz I if I take on a
595 Queen f6 g4 I was talking that and I
had something oh no no I I made a
mistake
instead of Ruki v after 94 I can play
Queen six here because there's no d6
after taking okay yeah it was my main
idea very interesting a very interesting
game and then it's it seemed like he
didn't really make many mistakes and
suddenly you're getting into a position
where where you know you're kind of
forcing to win the two bishops fall for
a rock and that III really liked the e3
move that you made and and also Bishop
g7 I was I found it yeah
because maybe here White has some
chances after after promotion takes
through to hold and I played this
because I have F to pawn and some
meeting ideas but that was a very
beautiful final move and that puts you
and on top of the standings thank you so
much for joining us today and we should
be luck in the next round and we hope to
see you back here do all right thank you
alright so we have to the standings
right now on the first place
Arron Asham above with four and a half
points leading the tournament by one
point
next Geoffrey Zhang Daniel narrowed its
key and Sam 7 both with three points and
a half
still have Gregory of Paran playing his
game against Victor Erdos we'll see if
Gregory will get back to you know to be
closer closer to the leader and yes
thanks for joining me back yeah okay
sorry I kind of went a little bit you
took my job I'm so sorry
so as we were saying Gregorio proned
last week we checked in we actually
think he's just losing in that endgame
yeah it was kind of tough so it looks
like after today those top four players
are going to be by far your clear
leaders with Sethu actually being number
five on 50% yeah there's a very nice
comeback for him losing Victor Erdos
Alexis Tirana and Barco B and rounding
out that acre yes to grab the beer oh
yeah of course
Sergey Azeroth and Alexis Sorokin
maintain their leadership positions both
only managing a draw today and actually
I think both were under some pressure
but especially Azeroth in that game he
said this is losing it I just yeah we
thought he was losing so it should be
good for them it should feel good to get
a half point yeah
stay you know in the first place and
then get that half point put that game
out of your mind let's pretend it didn't
happen
and then move on to it's a good chest
tomorrow Melik option federico poncy and
Emilio Cordova I'll stay just a
half-point back it's anyone's tournament
here in the B group G ground root Union
is still playing against Christopher
Oeste for you and Justin wing is still
trying to hold against tell Sean
morontia body although we think that
game is looking quite quite good for al
shot mm-hmm Sergei Arenberg also drew
his game and so why don't we check back
in one last time we see those players
there and I'll shut seems to be up a
clean pond in a rook end game and I
don't know do you know your rook and
games better than I know mine this
should be this should be reading about
what four versus two is
very very powerful yes because you
should you know start pushing your enf
bones make sure that a pond is not going
to cause too much trouble keep your look
behind it and no seventh-ranked and I
feel that whites should be winning here
expecting a win for Elle shot well we'd
like to thank you guys very much for
joining us here today that's just about
it for our coverage be sure to tune in
tomorrow for round seven live at 3:30
p.m. we will be back here same host this
time I'm not going anywhere and will
love to give you the coverage over that
yeah and thanks everyone from the
production to make this videos possible
shout-out to been better
Isak Tony a whole crew yeah so thank you
very much for joining us
be sure to tune in tomorrow for more
live coverage of the winter chess
classic this has been a presentation of
the st. Louis chess club
you